[Music]
my my goal one day was to try to
understand my behavior when using my
computer and actually my goal is to
understand my behavior and lucky me I'd
spend most of my time in front of a
computer so I have a tool that's
available most of the time and so the
the first goal is to understand what I
do and the second goal which I managed
to do somewhat less was to predict what
I'm about to do so a couple of examples
of this are I might be interested in
knowing say when I take a pause if my
pauses are really as short as they as I
think they are answer No or another
thing is sort of like in terms of
prediction can I predict when I'm
getting ready to be distracted when I'm
soon to be distracted it would be really
lovely to have sort of the equivalent of
one of those things that they have in
the United States for car drivers that
wake you up when you're about to fall
asleep so so that's sort of the goal the
caveat is that it's it's a side project
right and it's a it's not even my most
important side project so it's something
I use to learn about things it's
something that is really fascinating and
I get to do some interesting stuff and
in particular it gives me a chance to
play with technologies to learn
technologies that I don't get to play
with it work but and I'm going to saying
that here just so that you understand
that my my goal in that and my goal in
this talk is to sort of lead you through
them I want to lead you through the
adventure more than I want to show you
any particular results that came out of
it because really the result is going to
be that you know just does this because
but but the the progression of how the
thinking goes and how the how all of
this goes is perhaps more interesting
and more general so the first question
is where does the data come from well it
comes from my computer right but what do
I have in my computer that tells me what
I'm doing
and I'm I'm a Linux guy so there's this
concept of active window which anyway so
I wrote a script that keeps track of the
title of the active window and so once a
minute it while I'm logged in once a
minute it it writes down the name of the
active window and a timestamp and then I
was chatting with a friend who said well
why don't you keep the whole window
that's an idea so it turns out that even
with my high DPI screen which has more
pixels than I ever imagined
I can take a screenshot of it and then
reduce it to a 100 by 100 pixel postage
stamp without noticing that I've done
anything particularly intensive so
that's kind of neat I'm happy that my
computer is is powerful so now I have
these little postage stamps and they're
time-stamped also so then the question
is what can I do with all of this so
this is an example of the sort of thing
that I get right is this thing here a
laser well now that this tree isn't so
doesn't matter so um so it's a time
stamp and then the name of the window
title while I was writing these slides I
mean I just grabbed the line the last
line at some point while I was writing
the slides this is an example of a
hundred pixel by a hundred pixel image
thumbnail it's it keeps the the original
aspect ratio it turns out that even
within 100 by 100 pixels you can get a
pretty good idea of of what's going on
so what was I doing here Gmail yeah what
was I doing here yeah more more
particularly what's the application it's
a terminal right and here
yeah Google Docs good I love hanging out
with geeks because you recognize exactly
which document editor and in this one
exactly this is an Emacs window so so
quite surprisingly I now have on my
computer the most sensitive data about
my personal life that I ever thought I
would have you know I encrypt all my
passwords but this stuff isn't encrypted
and it's it's kind of sobering in a way
there's been some work on super
resolution and I was hoping to have time
to do that as an experiment before this
talk but plant I didn't have that kind
of time and the idea is that you train a
neural net on sort of image thumbnails
that are entirely greeked like this and
it's a supervised context where you give
it the original non reduced window on
the side as the C as the expected output
and it actually learns to take things
like this and reproduce the text that
was in it which is really kind of scary
and kind of cool at the same time right
I didn't have time to check it for mine
and I'm not even sure if I have enough
disk space to store all of the full-size
windows that I need to get a decent
training set but it's something I want
to try someday so the first rule of
machine learning is not to do machine
learning right so let's look at the data
and see what we can learn from just just
from looking at the data
so here blue is my desktop and red is my
laptop this is time in days and this is
time during the day I cut out the the
labels here because I was afraid that it
would not be visible though clearly I
didn't have had that fear on these
screens but um so one of the things you
can see is when I take holidays you can
see when I took a holiday into Asia and
in Australia and and and you can see
things like I tend to use my desktop
during the day and my laptop more in the
evening right so so right away just
visualizing this and things some
interesting things that I can
can learn about myself even though I
might have suspected that without
looking at the data I can also look at
my usage during the day and this is
where I discovered that when I think I'm
taking a 10-minute pause to get a cup of
tea I'm often taking a half-hour 45
minute pause to take a cup of tea so
feedback is always a good thing this is
over a slightly longer period of time
and you can see the weekends right I
mean this is a day when I wasn't working
and weekends
weekends also tend to have more laptop
usage than then than weekdays for
example so you see the you see lots of
read every 7 on a cycle of seven so
supervised learning is we're going to
say easy right because the next slides
is unsupervised and so I really want to
sort of stay in this context of
supervised learning the advantage of
unsupervised learning is that the lots
of values right one of the big
advantages of unsupervised learning is
that labeling is hard and expensive and
that's that's the case for me also I
have about 300,000 points 300,000
observations and labeling those points
is tedious as all get-out and being a
good computer scientist computer
programmer I'm lazy and so I'll go to
great lengths with software to try to
avoid try to avoid doing manual work so
I played around with quite a bit of
stuff but I'm actually not very good
with neural networks that's not the
stuff I do every day of every day of my
life so I was sort of trying to leave
that part till the end to the to the
extent that I could and we'll get into
exactly how that works I put in a little
bit of sort of basic theory but I'm
pretty sure I don't need it here so
we'll just skip over that the the
general strategy here is that I first
want to look for features figure out
what sort of features are interesting
and label those features and then I want
to auto label the rest of the features
right I want to come up with some tech
Niq so that i can label a few of the
points and then have the have the
computer going suggest a label for the
rest and then I just sort of have to
reality check that a little bit and then
it and then I want to form sequences of
things and then finally what I'd love to
do is is actually predict something so
everyone's heard a bag of words has
anybody not heard a bag of words
excellent okay just a couple we'll go
through it in about ten seconds
just for the couple people who said no
but so the strategy is that I want to
use bag of words and then I want to use
tf-idf anybody not know tf-idf I don't
mean to single people out I'm just the
negative is the more interesting number
right now Thanks
it's term frequency and inverse document
frequency the idea is that I want to
look at the words that show up often but
I want to wait less the words that show
up in lots of different documents here
each line each window title is a
document right so so if a word shows up
in lots of window titles in some sense
it doesn't carry as much meaning as
something that shows up in just a few of
them I'm not entirely sure that that's
completely useful for me because for
example Emacs shows up in a lot of
window titles and it actually is
significant because it says that I'm
developing one of most of the time and
also is playing with word Tyvek to see
if that could help me a little bit and
then the strategy is to find a sequence
based on this stuff so this is the
10-second introduction to bag of words
for those who haven't seen it you take
some words you number them because
computers deal with numbers then you
forget the words and just remember the
numbers and then you say well actually I
want to know the position of these
things so so one is 1 and 6 is 6 and so
forth and and then that's called a 1 hot
and coding and so our original sentence
translates to that is one hot encoding
and it's called bag of words because we
just collect the set of words that are
in the in the document and forget about
the order
good that's the fastest bag avoids
explanation you'll ever hear and and
then let me talk a little bit about
images because that's the other piece of
this is sort of what do I I thought I
had one more slide about this I'm pretty
sure I have another slide about about
the text part but apparently I misplaced
it after this bit about images so let me
just say what I was going to say the
[Music]
when I started playing with this and
looking at the looking at the data what
I discovered was that I really needed to
label more data and labeling the data
turns out to be painstakingly boring I
don't have the option of you know hiring
somebody to do it for me or something
like that right I have to sit there and
I wrote a little program that just shows
these things to me one at a time and and
lets me choose from the the categories
I've got so my data ended up being
dirtier than I would have liked and
saying with the results so I can't
actually tell you whether tf-idf forward
to vac worked better for getting me for
giving me a decent sequence of labels
because both of them were dirty enough
that that it was clear that my first
step really should be cleaning up the
adding more labels and cleaning up the
labeling so that I had a better strategy
the idea for auto labeling was simply to
do a nearest-neighbor assignment right
so every point that doesn't have a label
on it we say well what are the labeled
points that you're closest to and as
long as you're sort of closest to only
one guy then say ok that's going to be
your label and then where can I go from
there and as I said it turns out I just
need to label more points to get really
clean data so I don't feel comfortable
saying which technique worked better or
what sort of technique I should use in
the future because it's clear what my
first step of optimism optimizing this
should be the other thing that that this
brought up is that so some of you who
are say like my age will remember 15
years ago when some
would be talking about a home project
and he would reveal that he hadn't been
using source code control on his home
project
now with github they've game aside it
and I want to make that little brown
square darker so I commit many times a
day if I can but but but there's always
this temptation when you're doing a side
project at home not to use sort of
formal techniques so okay I did use git
for this stuff and and I threw stuff
away and I rewrote stuff and all that
but one of the things I didn't do was to
when I got bad results I didn't write
down just how bad the results were
because I knew they were bad and I knew
I needed to repeat them of course if I'd
been at work I would have kept these
nice plots so that when my boss comes
along and says you know what the heck
you're you know you're not me here I
could say yeah but it used to be here
and that's that's always nice to show so
it's sort of a reminder that that even
on home projects and personal projects
it's nice to keep nice to keep a good
solid technique
Ian Oswald is he here now
so anyway probably all know again so we
can about the sneaked notes for himself
about how to do data science and it's
it's worth reading once in a while
because it reminds me of things like
this in this particular case I was
preparing this talk when I said it would
have been really nice to have had the
sequence of how it improves over time
but I don't have that sorry so with
images I'm going to jump through this
because you've probably all seen em
missed and and you've probably already
recognized this as the classic M best
data right so I threw this in because I
wasn't at all sure what the what the
level of what the level of people here
would be so so anyway so remember we're
talking about that is words word two
back so we're Tyvek oh yeah that's the
reason I put that there was word to vac
the idea is that you train this very
simple neural network to do basically
dimensionality reduction which gives you
this lower dimensional space the problem
with the the problem with doing any sort
of nearest neighbor assignment when
you're in a very high dimensional space
if there's a lot
space in a high dimensional space this
is an interesting point of theory does
everybody know the curse of
dimensionality anybody not let me phrase
it another way if there were a smart
ten-year-old next to me and who said
what's the curse of dimensionality could
you explain it in a way that the
ten-year-old can understand who could
think they could do that okay so let me
go through a quick a quick tiny bit on
the curse of dimensionality tube just to
sort of highlight why it is I believe
that I want to reduce dimensions there's
a lot of space in big spaces so if I
take a unit cube in n-dimensional space
it has volume one right if I make that
unit cube D 1 plus epsilon on each side
all right as n goes to as n increases
without bound the volume of that cube
also increases that I've found even
though I've increased it only by Epsilon
and same thing if I decrease it by
Epsilon the volume of the cube goes to
zero right which means that any any
cubic subset of a unit cube in n
dimensional space is arbitrarily small
dimension which is just really weird
another way of thinking of this space
proper two other ways I think the space
problem is to think of the longest
diagonal so my sack of words space the
space with the one hot encoding has
dimension about 50,000 all right so that
means the longest diagonal in that space
in a unit cube is the square root of
50,000 right so this is just a lot of
space in that space so doing a nearest
neighbor encoding the risk is that that
sort of everything is too far away from
everything else and so you lose some
sort of context of of neighborliness one
other way of thinking of it is if you
think of the number of quartets in a
unit to attend dimensions this to to the
end of them and so that leaves a lot of
places for everybody to be on his own so
this is nearly useless graphic but that
it's kind of fun this is the machine
that the word to that guys
used nickel often guys you stirred to
computer thing and you probably all seen
this because I known that live was going
to present twice and Jen's him and
explain this stuff I wouldn't need to to
do this it gets tiresome to quote Google
other times on his list
I tried projecting the entire space so I
took this took my fifty thousand
dimensional space and projected it to
two dimensions
realistically I should have used T SNES
to do this
I used this projection whose name I can
never remember that just happens to be
in scikit-learn and and it doesn't
matter right because the oh the only
goal was to see does it show up in a
bunch of blobs and the answer is it
doesn't this enlighten structure I took
one of the nearest neighbor and codings
and that's nice to see that they all
sort of project together but it's it's
not very meaningful but it's nice to
draw pictures of your data even if you
don't think you're going to learn too
much from that particular picture what
would have been fascinating is if I'd
seen more things like this right
exciting you know one of these here and
one of these here and one it was here um
in fact it's not entirely clear that
there's this big SWAT here and I don't
yet know what it is it occurred to me
when I was watching Guillaume's talk
this morning he had a graphics something
like this and I'm I'm color blind so I
always forget to put color in my slides
because I just forgot and it occurred to
me that I might have done something
where I showed quite a few of the
clusters that I found and projected them
to this thing but the problem is those
pictures aren't meaningful to me because
I can see about three or four colors at
a time before it starts to all blend
together and so I don't think of that
until there's somebody around looking at
it reminds me but anyway good so this is
the sort of sequence that I get jelly
books is my company so my you know Jeff
ebooks development and then I check
something on Stack Overflow and
you know trying to figure something out
and then I'm doing more development so
that's the sort of sequence I'm looking
for this is what am i doing and that's
the sort of stuff that I get one of the
things that I didn't anticipate when I
started the project is that there are
there are things where I look at it and
I know what I was doing but I have no
idea how to tag it I don't know what to
call that particular thing and I started
coming up with names like life but but
I'm not sure that that's going to be
very useful or or predictive type of
label but it's sometimes it's the only
one I could come up with so now in terms
of in terms of images we have exactly
the same same the same sequence of
things that we do right we're going to
come up with features we want to label
them we want to go into Auto labeling
and come up some sequences of labels
right and eventually predict
so the first start of this is label is
labeling and I did exactly the same
thing as I did with the with the window
title so hide sort a little program that
showed these things to be one at a time
enormous ly magnified so I could see it
and then I would just type what I
thought I was doing and to be fair I oh
this is a piece of one of Google's
machines which I didn't really want to
go into um so to to be fair I wanted to
start with the sort of the simplest
thing I could possibly start with so for
features I simply took color histograms
of of each of the images and it turns
out that that's not an entirely dumb
thing to do because for example Emacs
window terminal windows are almost all
black and white well with grey Emacs and
syntax colouring any web site it turns
out that their branding gives them some
very unique color signatures so it turns
out that I can do something sort of
region of
with that the the next thing that I want
to do with that decide to clean up my
data but as I've pointed out and sort of
constantly procrastinating on that
because that's the least fun part of the
project is there are so this thing is
these two things are pieces of the
machine from the 2012 google paper where
they recognized captioning in YouTube
videos that's the cat that they
recognized they and we also in 2012 we
all sort of thought that that this was
amazing that they had this 9 layer
neural network but since then the visual
geometry group at somewhere came up with
a neural network that they called vgg 16
because there are 16 layers and then
shortly after that 9vg gene item because
there was 19 hidden layers and and they
published an a they made available the
the trainer model for free and then
Microsoft I think it was did ResNet
which is a 50 layer neural network so so
this is great because these people are
publishing the trained models which
saves us a lot of time if you put an
image into this model what comes out the
the exit neurons are things like this is
a coward this is a kangaroo or this is a
dog and I'm pretty sure that I don't
have that in my images but if I look at
the layer one under this and now I'm
talking about things that I haven't done
but I would like to do if I look at the
the N minus 1 layer in principle is
recognized most of sort of interesting
features without abstracting that to
what those features are and it should
give me a pre trained model that will
give me some interesting feature vectors
right because I can look at which
features of the of that n minus 1 layer
has lit up and and then I can explore
maybe I may need to look at n minus 2 or
something like that but it's it's a way
of generating synthetic features and
it's sort of a hack but it's a hack that
seems like it ought to work because we
all sort of know how these convolution
network should have build things up by
by shape sequences so the sequences here
look a little bit different though right
because I thought it would be cheating
to say that's an MX window and I know
what I was editing was so I just said
it's an E maximum Diller it's a terminal
or something like that so the same
sequence before look something like this
when it came to when it came to the
actual window thumbnail now in terms of
prediction this is a piece of the the
project that has forever been on the
to-do list because I haven't quite
gotten I'm not too interested in
predicting if I don't believe that I'm
labeling Auto labeling correctly but or
with reasonably good accuracy so the
idea with predicting is that I take a
sequence of things so it's still
supervised learning I take a sequence of
things that have happened and then I
take the sequence of things that happen
right after and that's what I give to
the to the classifier and I say I said
hey here's your input here's your output
and then I start trying to get it to
predict on on you know on the testing
set where I don't get at the output my
plan for this and those of you if those
of you in here who know neural networks
better than I can can offer me feedback
on it but my plan for this was just to
use like a simple multi-layer perceptron
to see what I could do with the fixed
window size because again I'll I always
think that I should start with the sort
of simplest thing I can and then we'll
go from there
the code and I need to push in and merge
a branch before this will actually look
right but the code is here if you want
to look at it for reasons that seems
logical at the time but no longer make
any sense at all I did not use pandas
for this project I used some other nice
features in Python I would be astonished
if anybody really got into this enough
to want to submit pull requests from my
personal project but then a year ago I
might have been astonished at the idea
that of
and people will be sitting here
listening to me tell you about my
personal project so if if you look at
this and you get frustrated but it's not
pandas I would accept such a pull
request it's just you know not something
I've gotten around to doing and with
that any questions any questions well I
actually have one have you tried looking
at recurrent neural networks so
predicting from their special well
before the sequence prediction bar codes
could they're well optimized for
sequence yeah that's a good idea
um I thought about it and and then it
really came down to sort of the a friend
of mine said well you know and a
multi-layer perceptrons going to be
easier and simpler you might try that
first and I thought yeah it is a bit
simpler I even understand MLP a little
bit better than I understand recurrent
networks so maybe I'll try that first
but yeah we're current that work would
be a good idea I thought about using
lsdm and I was roundly told that was
crazy because so the idea with Alice TMS
is that maybe you can you can understand
history without specifying a window size
and I was roundly told that I was
getting too complicated and I should
drop that idea yeah so apart from taking
shorter breaks now did you learn
anything changes most of what I learned
is about is about data science and about
the algorithms I'm playing with because
most of them like you know work to vex
for example is something that I'd read
the papers but until I actually started
playing with it I you know like I
understand it very differently once I
start to play with it so yeah I mean
it's good to have a reason to be doing
these things in order to do them I
suspect that the most fascinating thing
I could possibly learn is if I could
manage to predict when I'm going to get
distracted and warn me against that I
suspect that this is some
we'll be unlikely to predict accurately
because if I build a predictor and it's
a 90% accurate that means 10% of the
time I'm going to distract myself by
telling me I'm about to be distracted
and that would probably be worse so the
chances of my getting something running
accurately enough to run on my machine
so it pops up something that says wake
up Jeff it seems small but yeah I'd love
to figure out a periodicity for a pill
third question yeah hi thanks that was
really interesting like you say the
journeys sometimes more interesting from
the result and did you could you say
something about your experiences around
hitting performance issues and what you
did about it on your loans yeah that's
interesting so I very quickly came came
up with a performance issue just on
loading and saving the data set and my
solution was to suck it up and say I
don't want to spend the development time
to switch to a proper database I'm just
going to continue doing a full load and
save every time the I was actually
astonished at how fast most of these
things run now I have an 8 core i7
machine here right so it's it's four
times to four Hardware people but it's
it's an eight something I seven and and
I'm I was astonished to how fast these
things ran I didn't really have to wait
for anything besides the data to
actually load from the bit about I was
running about 18 seconds for the did it
actually loaded into the program on each
run so I sometimes have fun in
in-between press the products and that I
find that some of the harder problems to
solve are when you hit memory issues
rather than kind of CPU kinds of issues
did you come closer to that I didn't on
but then I did some back of the envelope
calculations and said well on the you
know my future vectors are
[Music]
what my future vectors are you know okay
the 50,000 in the case of the of the one
hot encoded window titles but I'm only
doing computations based on the training
set which is what I've labeled so since
I haven't labeled 50,000 things or a
hundred thousand things I don't actually
have to train on that for the for the
images since I'd reduced to playing with
color histograms again I had seven
hundred and what's two fifty two fifty
six times 3/7 well whatever's seven
hundred something so I've you know the
700 and something wrong vectors of of
data about each window and again it
didn't it didn't turn into anything that
was overly complex for my mission if I
tried to do something where I was
processing all of the data at once with
maybe only a 20% holdout for testing
because I really believed that my auto
labeling is working then I could imagine
I might have had that problem but I tend
to do to stay with a much smaller data
size I'm actually there was one time
where I was playing with something where
I it was taking too long and I just
started taking random samples of the the
data set so that I was smaller yeah this
is any more questions there's one up
front monitor
he's been smiling through the whole
talks I want to know he says hey you
said about recording your camera and
something with that like analyzing your
facial expression oh man yeah and I
should keep track of GDD state when I'm
doing that too just so I could see if
there's a correlation um I haven't
that'd be kind of fascinating
I was curious also if I could get it to
the point where I could sort of identify
when I was having video chats with
people who I was chatting with but I
that was a refinement I never got to any
other questions well I think there's
another end to the source
[Applause]
[Music]